uh good afternoon everybody my name is
Mike mullo
and I'm I'm the python trainer for spice
and Academy so we do python training
since 2006.
and we do a lot of different kinds of
python training and Drury pricing
training Advanced pricing training pass
training for scientists or one of our
courses or tutorials is faster python
programs through optimization and that's
what I'm going to go through
today this is actually the handout you
have is a little bit it's like a
tutorial for a little bit longer for for
a few more minutes than we have here
therefore we have to go over a few
things but I still should give you some
kind of general idea about how to
optimize program the optimization people
ask me is about it's not optimizing some
numerical problems or something like
this but optimizing pricing programs
make them run faster and it's a it's
like more like a basic introduction what
you can do and what python can offer
here so everybody should pick up a
handout they're located there and here
so there's some paper that goes with it
and also you can download
to source code so if you go to this URL
you will find the examples we want to
work with
so
we probably don't have too much time to
actually do too much exercises that
tells also a few tools you might you
would need to install so I actually
haven't sent out the links on there you
would need to install them most of them
could be installed with ground or pip or
something like this but actually since
we don't do the exercises not so
essential to have it I will show most of
the things here which would surface for
this type of tutorial because we only
have 80 minutes which is not a lot so
I'm doing an exercise usually takes
10-15 minutes so that you cannot do but
you're welcome to work along do do
things with me if you like a lot of
things just work with playing python
there's quite a few things and also you
can work with a
um
download if you have a download or the
other source code is in there and you
can should most of them should work just
out of the box
okay
so a question who view is using python
uh
less than one year
okay people lesson two
lesson five
more than five
okay it's a pretty good mixture of
people uh that that work with python
though this this optimization tutorial
is not necessarily strictly for
scientists for python programs in
general so isn't that that's nothing
special for scientific or data
applications here but for how you can
make python programs faster in general
and for this there's a few rules
that
you can use
okay
let's start quickly so that's pretty
much what's in the handout so the first
question if you talk about making things
faster actually doing do you need the
make it far so that's that sounds like a
stupid question but this is really a
question you should ask yourself how
fast is fast enough
and this is something you really need to
take into the consideration
what do I need do I need to make my
program fast or not what does it mean to
make it faster because typically if you
make things faster very often it comes
at some cost so it's not for free you
have to spend time on it and you might
make your code more complicated
the nice thing would be making your code
more readable and fast at the same time
there are some sometimes you can do this
but sometimes you have to make your code
more difficult you have to install
libraries and you have to write more
code and you try things to make it
faster so passion
it's interpreted every people say python
is slow but for a lot of things actually
python is not that slow if you compare
with with other languages there are
quite a few things where python
is not that slow of course for numerical
computations when you do this pure
python is rather slow but there are a
lot of solutions and I want to show with
you here you can use though it seems
like getting more and more solutions and
it's kind of difficult to keep track
which ones are the ones to use but I
make a few suggestions uh what you can
do so premature optimization is the root
of all evil that's one of those famous
things here people say and that's
something really really important though
optimization is not something you should
start out with optimization should be at
the end of some kind of uh Pro process
you brokers
so there's a few rules so I wrote them
down so the very first thing is you have
to make sure your program is really too
slow
do you really need more performance just
if you spend a few days optimizing your
program and the whole thing whole
program just runs once that doesn't
might not make sense to put a lot of
time into optimization and there might
be a lot of other factors that are not
actually python related that are can
impact your performance and that's the
first part we spend on here is actually
measuring what's going on that's that's
the essential part of optimization you
have to measure things
and those things and it's really
necessary to to put this extra effort in
there that's a question you should
repeatedly ask yourself
and then for sure don't optimize as you
go sometimes you have a gut feeling
those things is faster than the other
thing
which is tempting but I have to say very
often I'm wrong what's first and what's
what's slower and guessing it's maybe
not not a good strategy you really have
to go and measure and also use only
realistic use cases don't just okay this
thing has to scale and has to get very
big maybe it doesn't get big maybe to do
something else maybe you don't need
needs to have this performance and also
architecture how you set things up can
be very essential for performance and
this can be something that has nothing
to do with python itself but with a lot
of other things so performance over
difficult that can be a lot of things
involved and it's not really clear on
the beginning what is actually that's a
problem
and often do you have bugs
and and the first thing you knew you you
should do actually you should do
profiling is what we're going to do and
also when you do optimization you
change your code and you might introduce
bugs you might change what's coming out
that's very important to to really keep
track that that you don't change what
your program is doing yeah first make it
work right and then make it work fast
it's very important uh to do and we're
going to look at a few of the things
what you can do for this so there might
be some things that
that might slow your program down has
nothing to lose price on one of the
networks network connections one of them
you can have a database so we have
system calls to the operating system all
kinds of things it can be can make your
program slow and this is sounds a little
bit very common sense but it's important
that you actually uh
do this and
work with
those questions also ask them you're
repeatedly going through because
optimization can be can mean quite a bit
of effort so it can mean quite a bit of
time you spend on your program and in
the end it might turn out it's not worth
it because you that you don't know if
you do optimization in the beginning if
you really
can get something
something out of it
so one thing you can do when you work
with uh
with python you can use python
Pipestone is a test in Python
you can work with so let's go to our
notebook
so you can say
import
type Stone and python gives you some
kind uh no sorry you have to there's a
Pipestone in the library test there's a
uh
there's a module python you can use and
you can measure the pi stones
of your of your system so if you go to
the to the library where things are
installed you can use pipe Stones
actually I have maybe it's nicer to show
it to you here because I have several of
those things executed so if you go to
the
that doesn't work
okay I have have it here shown you we
have pythons if you run this one it's
look located in the directory of your
python store directory for different
python versions I did it and you run Pi
Stone and then you get uh a pistol
measurement which gives you some kind of
uh
some kind of Benchmark benchmarks always
a problem but some kind of Benchmark to
see how fast your python implementation
is in general and you can can do this
and you can compare different python
versions here and see how fast they are
and you can see how many Pi Stones per
second you have that's something
I did here for several versions Python
2.7 and for other python versions like
Pi Pi so if you use Pi Pi or iron python
you might see a quite a bit different
results you see the the the numbers here
going up with this iron Python and Pi Pi
and this Pi stone measurement gives you
some kind of Baseline how fast your
python is there's always a problem that
doesn't apply to everything but you can
see how fast your python actually works
and if you repeat the test is it
sometimes might get get even faster
from testing pipe Stones you see you
have the code here I've forgotten
actually so you can import this from
test and you can make can run this on on
your menu machine so everybody that has
a
from test import
one and you can run it and you can see
the measure for your for your machine
but it doesn't work
it should there should be in the
standard Library
no no test is not in there
it's probably something I didn't try
this is installation so you should
always try things then you have this
nice effect here
works
so there's there's another there's a
there's a different test here installed
and then you use IPython the IP is a
notebook so if I go to the if I go to
the normal python interpreter and start
python here then it works so it's a
standard installed and it didn't try it
there they have a normal Python 2.7 and
if I say from test
import
one then you get the pipe Stone
here and then you can now it works you
see it should be there I don't know why
it's not working in an ipis notebook I
haven't tried it from there and then you
can have use pipestone.pystone you get
measure of those Pi stones and this is
some
Pi Stones it's in plural
yeah and then you get a measure how long
it takes and you see you have this this
numbers here and this is something you
can compare different python stalls and
different computers this would be
something if you if you run the program
a different with different installations
of python and different
um
different computers you might use this
one
to work
with it so let's let's I wrote a small
program that helps you actually convert
things to Pi stones
so if you go to if you open um
measuring
pistone converter this is a small python
converter actually that doing exactly
this it Imports the pi Stone
here and then it converts to kilo python
because python is a very big number and
they're divided by 1000 if you're even
bigger you might even buy a convert by
another number then you get some kind of
measurement and this measurement you can
use to compare different pythons
implementations that might be useful for
a few things
okay
let's go the first thing the very big
important thing is when you work if you
look at code it's it's profiling
though the profiling thing
that's my past I don't think the
profiling thing uh you you should you
want to profile how much CPU you use
you're also going to look at profiling a
memory usage but the first thing is you
want to look at the cpu's usage and
there are several tools there's profile
HotShots but the recommended tool is C
profile do you do c profile but the
problem is if you do profiling it always
introduces them overhead and this
overhead might pretty much distort your
profiling results
therefore you should use C profile which
tries to minimize the overhead and it's
doing just
uh
kind of a good job
giving you some kind of reliable results
so let's have a look at um let's let's
have a look at a small program that I
wrote that's called profile me so if I
say load
oops I'm the wrong one
loads you can open an editor of course
measuring
profile me then I just wrote a program
here with two functions you see you have
two functions one is Fast and the other
one is slow
and then I used fast and use slow and
then I
run this I have this program and now you
can use C profiler to program this and
in if you use ipis notebook actually
it's built in already the printout here
has how you how you can do this when you
import profiler yourself but if you're
an iPad so notebook actually you can use
a that
profile option here P run
and if you do this it's running your
your program under the profiler and
should give you some still running it
should give you some output and showing
you what happens and that's exactly what
over the handout also says so the
profile is running your program and
gives you a very nice statistics what's
going on so you can see what happens and
you can see which function actually it
took how much time you see now you can
actually see where the time goes you
have the total time it takes for the
whole thing the time for one call and
the cumulative time which in this case
is the same here and you see I have 200
calls to this timing module here and it
tells you that it's called that many
times and how long it takes
ticks per call
and then you see some some of the
numbers are so small they don't even
show up because they have this rounding
here they don't show up but then you can
really most of the time this is a very
useful tool because now you can really
see the bottleneck which function uh
call or method call takes up most of the
time in your program and very often you
have the case that only a few functions
take up most of the time
that might be cases there do you have a
lot of function to take up
more time but here you can already see
that this one function time that there's
a Time sleep that where the time goes
and where things happening and you can
really tell
what's going on
here
and then if if you want to look at the
statistics here if you do this you can
import it and get import C profile you
can also write a program like this you
don't have to do only an ipis notebook
which is nice for interactive work but
sometimes if you want to profile more
you can profile more you can see more
outcome there and then you have the
statistics you see you have a number of
calls there you have the total time
the protocol time
uh and so on cumulative time and also
the line number that gives you quite a
few uh information about your program
and this is something you should always
do if you're an Ibis notebook you can
also use I used here in this case this
double P run but you can also
use a simpler thing you can
use a profile
is one percent sign so if you work on an
IPython the one percent of us concerns
more or less one line and you have two
percent sign it concerns the whole cell
so now you could measure how long things
take to compare
the the runtimes and this one gives you
should
give you something
should never
well I'm not sure why it's not working
you should give me them
did it so many times and it's just not
going to work now
I'm not sure what's wrong
should give me the the output from from
one line
so this one
this is a full
no sorry
time it it's time it
so I'm not right here yet it's time it
and time it is doing what you want to
time it is it's not a real profiling
time it's just gives you the runtime of
this one line and with time it you can
time one statement in Python and you can
see how long it takes and as you see
it's doing hundred thousand loops and
you can tell how long it how long it
takes and if you do something else you
will get some other
other time measurement
yeah so you can run any kind of
so yeah double
so if it's if you use a double one you
can also use time it and time it is
smaller just gives you timing whereas
profile goes through the whole code and
gives you it's it's very useful if you
have a larger program with multiple
function calls because you see all the
function calls whereas time it you just
get the time measurement for the thing
what you're doing right now so this one
can help you to
do interactive thing and it's very nice
because you see you have a few examples
if you use time it from the stunt
Library you have to set up your code and
do a few steps here you can use it
interactively and you can quickly get a
feeling how fast things are and
sometimes you're surprised what is fast
what is not fast there's not always that
obvious and you can measure here and can
see how things how things work
they also different things if you import
the profile or you can import
uh C profile
SP so make a short then you can also use
the Make an instance of a profiler
here if you like to and then you can
have more
leverage and can just run single single
functions through this so import this
one and then I say
profiler
uh
Dot
run call and then you can run the code
that's different options what you can do
with it now I can specify the function I
would like to
to profile use slow so I imported the
whole thing in in my namespace here so I
can use a function if you do this in the
normal import then you might have to put
the module name in front of it and I
just import it here now you can run it
and it takes a takes a while
and this one doesn't show the output
here
which is unfortunate this hasn't I
haven't tried this in in the active ipis
notebook though the output is somewhere
else obviously
it's gone
now I have to have to get it out
profiler so it's not shown here profiler
dot
print stats and you'll get the
statistics now and you have this for
this one function so you can actually
sometimes you get a lot of output and
you're not interested in the whole thing
you just want to have a a part of the
the program then we can use runcall and
do this run call so there are multiple
options doing this uh profiling
and you can work with it and you can
also if you like to you can also store
the
this results in a file and then there
are a lot of tools actually use working
on the files we're going to look at one
of those tools that helps you to
to get a good feeling what's going on
because if you get a lot a big table
there's a lot of numbers it might not be
the best thing to look at and there are
some graphical tools that help you doing
doing profiling
so you can also
run a string so that's let's let's have
a look at here we have to go a bit
faster Maybe
so you can if you like to run a string
that's what I did uh so far I just put
in the function object itself but you
can also run put a string in here so a
string you could always generate on the
runtime and this gives you uh also the
output
for this for this function and now you
could also specify a file and so you now
specify the file F star fast Starts Here
and Now python stores the results of
this profiling in this file in this
there's quite quite a few tools that can
read this file later on the simplest one
would be reading it back here with with
the p stats here so
which I did here so you can run it and
then
you have this this file fast starts
which is produced here and then you can
look at the start so you can you can see
your table later on so this would be you
can put it in your program if I have a
bigger program and it's running longer
you can write your own small tools that
help you to do some profiling so maybe
your program gets stopped over and over
again and you want to profile things
then you can store those things in this
files and later on you can look at it
and read those files and get the
statistics back this would be one way
one way of doing it
and this can be very helpful we have
also a tool a graphical tool that helps
you to visualize so it's the things here
yeah but now you can print uh starts and
then you have different kind of sorting
options and you can just limit how much
output you want and you can sort things
in all kinds of
ways here you can sort it by time and
and show all lines or just have a
limited number and this is
pretty good analysis already and also
you have this caller so you can find out
who called whom and how this belongs
together here
which function is called you just starts
print colors and you just put in the
name and then you see
actually what happens and you can find
out which function calls which function
this is a very simple example here just
a few just two four functions in in
total but they have a real program there
might be a way more complex and it might
not be the obvious how things work and
this gives you some way to get some more
details what happened in your program
so and you can also have the other way
around so who called
by whom can be can be analyzed with a
Sprint starts kholis here and you get
this out
and find out what happens and then you
have a lot of Statistics total stats
gives you a total calls gives you so the
203 calls yeah they have two Loops
there's 200 each and three other
function calls outside that's the number
of calls you have so there's quite a bit
of information
uh the problem is maybe you have uh
too much information maybe and that's
why we have some graphical tools later
on to analysis
measuring time it's a different thing
difficult thing sometimes because as
soon as you measure influence your
system and you wanted you want to try to
reduce
the the influence of your system as much
as possible
and when you measure unfortunately there
are some differences between operating
systems if you just use time time that's
why here I have this uh
differences here you see I have four
different
uh
these different method is we use
different methods if I use clock here
and if I use time time so time clock is
one method to get a timestamp and time
time and a default timer and
unfortunately there are differences
between different operating systems so
if you run this on this this time time
or clock on different operating systems
you might get different results because
sometimes they have different meanings
and that's why it's recommended to use
time it's default timer to get a
timestamp so time it default timer gives
you gives you a timestamp here yeah they
all give you time stamps actually and
then you see I just subtract this when I
do is this is three methods I get a
timestamp before I run something and
then I get a timestamp after this here
and just get the difference between have
the three different methods and then
print out but those three different
methods give me
that's a typical way just get a
timestamp before one time step after
then you know how long it takes and then
if you do this then you see uh
oh it's times provides the CPU a time
and all operating systems
but with six decimals
if you do
uh a Time Clock there's a CPU time on
Unix but wall wall clock time on windows
so it's a different thing means a
different thing we have to be careful
but it's more accurate on Windows
because you get more decimals out of
that's why you should use default timer
to measure things so default time it the
module is doing this if you go to Python
3 they cleaned up it there's things up
you have some new time measurement
functions in Python 3 so you won't have
so many uh
operating system dependent thing so you
see here if you if I have this they only
have this this digits here not so many
digits and you have some differences in
the Precision and that's a problem it's
a Precision it's not good enough we
measure something then you might not be
able to measure what you're doing
because your time measurement Precision
is not good enough
that's why if you have strange results
which you might revisit what you did and
typically using time and default timer
is the right thing to do don't go just
for the normal time module
that's a different thing so if I do this
on Windows you see in Windows I get a
bit different results here this you look
you compare the uh this this time clock
you see the duration for the default
time was about one second and here takes
about 0.4 seconds time clock whereas
here uh time clock in the default time
will give you is the same result because
they are essentially it's the same thing
so you have to be careful if if your
program runs on different systems
suppose if you do the measurement office
on a Unix system then things might work
but if you move to a Windows system that
might be different that's why we should
use default timer
that we
that you can can use
so this is a small clip that helps you
to measure both the wall clock time and
CPU time so the wall clock time is
actually the time that that really runs
so you have a time Slam in front and a
Time slap in the end and that's really
the time that elapsed but the CPUs time
is just a time that really the CPUs it
was using for for your program because
typically on your computer you have to
load a lot of other things happening and
you would measure them also at the same
time if you measure work work time
uh and you don't measure the notation
methods uh CPU time and to do this here
isomotives have a small script which is
also on your hard drive on your download
and see this is just a few things so it
should run with Python 3 and make it
compatible with python 3.
renaming range in X range here
and then I have this this small helper
function here which can be useful so
depending on those your platform is the
windows win32
this box also works on within 64-bit 32
has nothing to do with a 64 bitness is
just the API so this should work with an
oracle on Windows versions you use OS
times zero otherwise use time clock
there's something at least some python 2
you have to do this to get a
a reasonable measurement of CPU time
and then if you use those two functions
on different operating systems I cannot
reach your windows here because I don't
have a Windows install here
I would need to open the machine which
takes too long but if you use this
functions here and just do this do a two
two Loops one is just sleeping for two
seconds and the other time is doing
something here adding one plus one uh
100 million times in the loop and I do
those things then I get get these
results
on here so I just profile
profile those two test methods and here
the profiler if you like to you can
supply a different method you can apply
a different function in this case the
function I just wrote myself just throw
it in and now you're not using the
default thing which is a which is a wall
clock time that meaning actually measure
into time that we elapsed but rather my
CPU time function which is different and
you get a different result so if you do
this here then you see the results at
this place
and if you compare the runtimes
you see a different
different
outputs this one is is a is a one with a
work work time and this one is one of
the CPU timing if you look at the
numbers of course the wall clock time
numbers must be bigger than the CPU
times because
the CPU time is really the time the
computer spent using CPU in your program
and the wall clock time would include
everything else that happens during the
time on your machine so even if a
multi-core machine typically uh
that other things happen here now you
have some a different number here and
you can distinguish between CPU time and
not CPU time and I have at least for
python 2 I haven't found the other
solution than writing this function
yourself so I go back here so this is a
function I used yeah so I use this OS
times gives you two but there's a lot
quite different times and the first
entry gives you the CPU time and on Unix
systems you can use clock for this
so that's important
to actually know what you're measuring
there can be a lot of pitfalls you think
you measure something but you measure
the wrong thing and have a wrong
understanding of it therefore those kind
of things
should be taken into account and as I
said you can supply your own
measure function
and here we have the the output at on
Linux machines and you oversee the the
time is also because now it's a little
bit different because there's a
different CPU and stuff like this so you
cannot really compare them by the
wireless compare you see now the the
world clock time is bigger than the CPU
time
you can do the same thing with Python 3
Python 3 also does it so it works and
then
this thing
yeah it's python 3.
so this is something I would like to
urge you to look at you always have to
know what you're measuring and happened
to me several times that you keep
measuring something and then your end
you realize you're mentioning the wrong
thing you're using the wrong method and
you have some assumption and you uh we
cannot really give too many General uh
um recommendations
only just have a look and try to figure
out what it's actually doing otherwise
you might go down the wrong path
okay let's look at some pictures so
there's a very nice tool called run
snake run so if you like you can install
it but maybe it's too much now just to
do in this tutorial you can download it
run snake run it's written in Python
surf using WX Python and square map and
it gives you a nice very nice
graphic view on on the statistics so we
use profiler you save your results in
the stats file and then you can use the
stats file to look inside
so and it looks like this this is my uh
my result of the program I just was
running and this is very obvious you see
all the time is spent in this and this
is a Time sleep so every all the time
spent and time sleep and you can really
see it at the first view how things
happen and all the rest is just a very
thin wrapper around calling this time
sleep
in the left hand side you can go through
and you can look at every single
function you have a lot of other Dynamic
things you can do here
and now uh
they have the next picture it's the same
thing type sleep
and this is your other one uh
where we have some more things going on
and this gives a bit more interesting
picture now so you have several
functions running and you can see how it
looks like and then this is this is an
example if you use numpy when do we do
the same thing the same thing we do with
the other function we just saw this
playing python use numpy you see numpy
is using a lot of libraries obviously a
lot of calls and it looks a bit
different so you don't have this nice
picture with one big block anymore
there's only
this here and you have a lot of things
happening and you can look at what
happens now of course it's much more
difficult to optimize because you don't
have this one picture of uh
uh working
and looking and you see okay this is a
function I need to optimize it's just
now two things and a lot of things are
internal in numpy you wouldn't be able
to optimize anyway this way you could
only optimize the usage of those
functions you know this function takes a
lot of time and if you could maybe
reduce the number of calls to the
function but it gets more much more
complicated and that's more how typical
program looks like and you can look at
every of the single boxes and can see
what you can do with it yeah and this
can be really useful
okay
Z profile Works only for full functions
so the the smallest unit you can have is
a function so you can look inside the
function but there's a helper here and
this helper is uh is line profiler so if
you use LINE profiler then you can go
and profile things and actually you get
an output like this
so you you have to kind of install line
profiler which is written in Python and
this gives you a
nice line by line breaks breakdown of
your call so if you do something like
this you get
um
this is normalcy profile output and the
line profilers you can use as a
decorator
and that means so if I put it in like
this so that's that's what I have here I
just put this Add profile in front of it
yeah
Add profile and then the line profile is
actually inspecting this function the
problem is line profiler puts a lot of
overhead on your program so makes things
a lot slower but still gives you some
kind of useful information about the
relative
time you use for every single line in
your program so using this this line
profiler can be useful if you have
methods that are longer and you really
want to know what's happening inside
those functions here and then you just
put this profile there
and
it's always easy to turn it off so it's
just on decorate so if you like to you
can just have a talk writer that's doing
nothing
and then the effect of line profiler
would would go away and then if you run
this here if you run it through this
this clone Prof it's written written by
Robert coron that's why it's called
Chrome Prof then you can go through line
by line
and then this takes apart your code line
and you see an output that gives you a
information about every line and see now
it repeats your source code here on the
right hand side
repeats your source code and gives you
information so the information here
how many times this this is called how
long it takes and how long it takes per
hit per run and then the percent of the
time so you can see now uh that this uh
the most of the time is spent 99.4
percent of the time is spent in this
fast call and only a very small actually
is for this for this x range here so the
obviously the core the function is much
more expensive than going through the
loop this is something C profile will
never give you but line profiler gives
you a signal if you do slow you see you
get even 100 because it's rounded to one
digit here then the slow so much slower
than it takes up 100 of the whole time
here and you see that that's a real
times yeah the the
Loop takes essentially the same you see
there are some differences it should be
the same number actually why should it
be different but there are some
difference in the number here so if you
repeat this run you might get some
different numbers
around some work Park but you can see
the time here for the for this uh slow
function is much bigger than for the
fast functions a much bigger number
and this is something this this line
profile I can give you can give you a
very nice
overview uh
of
things
to doing
now I wrote a small small uh example
here accumulate which accumulates the
the the
um
it's like if you calculate the sum of of
a list of numbers but you keep the
intermediate results you can use
accumulate and that's what I wrote and
just to see just as an example for my
profiler so I wrote a small function
here that's actually doing something and
it takes is iterable so it takes
anything that can be iterated over which
has numbers inside
and then I go through and then just
remember
and take the last element and just add
it to something appended of course you
don't you will never do this by hand if
you use numpy numpy at uh
accumulate its built in is much faster
but just as an example here you can use
it and you can accumulate things and now
it will accumulate for 100 and attendant
100 just use my function and then I run
it through my my current profiler and
see what's coming out
and
it shows me okay my file accumulate here
is run for a pretty short time
and then I get an output and I get a
very nice breakdown what's happening
here and you see uh how much time you
spent actually on which operation the
lock screen is no time here and then
just accessing this iterable zero is a
small portion of the time then going
through here on the slicing takes 23 of
the time and all this assignment takes
some time and they append it they'll
take pretty much the same time but 20 30
percent here and then they return and
then you can get feeling where you might
be able to to add this worthwhile to
optimize here in your in your Loop
so you can there's another one a very
interesting one so I have this
calculation here so mathematical
calculation as an example so I do this
average everything separately I just
generate number plus 10 times 10 the
power of 10 then I use the built-in
function power then I use mass square
root and I use square root which is
just import it yeah so I do import mass
and here I say Mass
square root just access to square root
and square root and this square root is
the is from is set up here so I just
make this shortcut and this way this can
be very interesting you see how much
time those things take
and if you go through then you have a
breakdown so I do
100 calculations here this is number and
then
uh
I look at the the breakdown when you see
the most time actually is spent in this
power function though the plus is very
very cheap yeah same thing plus 10 is
cheap compared to the power function and
you can see this double star on the
power function take about the same time
whereas the power function takes a bit
more time
and then if you use if you call mass
square root it's a bit longer not much
than usually using square roots because
the access to
this square root is a bit longer than
square root so that can be important if
you have a title Loop and do a lot of
things as access to this attributes if
you have a lot of attributes or any
access that might take time so that's
something uh you can do let's expand on
this idea a bit further so if you have
this
this function actually here we use this
this profile and that's just a dummy
this this doesn't do anything there so
this is dummy
uh
if you if you want to run it without the
profile then you can do something like
this otherwise we we have have a have a
have our own
um
uh profile function the thing is if if I
run a discount profit then then the
profile will be defined if the profile
is not defined I get a name error at
this place
then I Define my own decorate or my own
decorator that's doing nothing just
return the plane function so if you work
with decorators you might look very
familiar otherwise this is just a small
tooling to make it possible to keep this
ad profile in your code without any
changes and if you run it normally
nothing happens because only the
beginning this this this profile
function will be defined and we'll just
take any function and return the
function but this happens only at once
when you import your script
yeah everything gets like with this
profile otherwise uh the profile of uh
this uh
Kon Prof this line profiler is used
therefore you could keep the profile
inside your code and you wouldn't have
any overhead when you when you actually
run it that can be pretty useful
yeah who's who's for movies decorators
yeah only a few people so decorator is
is something this is a decorator and
this is doing something with a function
if you've simplify it and this means
this decorator which I Define here is
doing nothing with a function it keeps a
functional alone that's pretty much what
it's doing
yeah and this would be would make well
usually I don't like to put something
increment something out so you can keep
the ad profile in there and wouldn't
essentially would know would be me no
overhead and if you want the profile you
just can run it can't provide that's
that's something and it works uh
pretty nicely and this is only of course
only the module level if you wanted to
have a whole model you have to put it
into
a built-in switch is maybe not that nice
okay let's look at this local
referencing game here
so uh having this this uh this square
root here
the square root assigned so I do this as
this excess mass is a module from the
standard library in square root is a
function I'm using
and then uh I say for X for something in
in X range
and excess square roots and here I don't
do this I access Mass DOT square root
directly
and I would like to measure the
difference how long it takes just a
small thing if it doesn't make a
difference or not so it implemented
these two functions and then I do my
thing and run it with a profile and see
how long this takes here line by line
This align breakdown for those those
things
and then uh with a
this is a normal if I if I use it as a
normal Visa V option I get this normal C
profile output and you can see the C
profile output just gives you a uh this
by
by function call and then I can have it
with a
wizard with a minus L option and I get
it to get the breakdown line by line
when actually I see where the time sits
inside my my function
here and now you see if I if I call this
local ref here and the module if they
take about uh
the then time
but running actually running this
program if you run the command line you
see it takes much longer so line
profiler adds a lot of overhead to your
program so you usually you don't want to
have something running all the time with
you because it can make a program really
really slow you see the total Time Is
Here 125 seconds whereas here the the
total time
is 50 15 seconds so it's a big big
difference it's nearly an order of
magnitude difference if you use LINE
profile of as minus L instead of using
line profilers is a normal option which
is just essentially C profile so it
takes about 10 times as long really
and but you get a get this breakdown
here and you see what happens
and
the problem is line profile Works only
on the on the python level of course and
shows you only python function if you
work with numpy then you you don't see a
lot because you only see the calls of
from numpy
okay this is something that can be very
interesting to see where there is
potential to to make things to make
things faster
most of the time when you talk about
optimization you talk about
optimization of
CPU time but you can also optimize
memory so sometimes you have programs
that use too much memory and of course
as soon as as your program is kind of
swapping you this everything gets very
slow
and therefore there's also some tools
for memory usage and I've found too I'm
using here and I want to just introduce
them to you that you can see those tools
are there and they can be pretty useful
there are some tools in The Sound
Library you can get the the
this the size of memory of an object but
they are not as comprehensive as those
tools the first tool is actually hepi
from The Guppy framework that helps you
to analyze
um
memory it's just as everything is just
python 2 so it doesn't work for Python's
read as far as I know
maybe there's some new compile and just
they had their problems to move into 2.7
but now there are two also available 2.7
and here you can get that get the get
the fingerprint how much memory is used
at any given time in your system and you
can also break it down who's using
memory this can be useful if I have a
problem if if your program is running
for violence using more and more memory
and it shouldn't then this one can give
you some some help let's look at some
example how you can do this so you just
import you say Heap
HP which I imported here yeah
I Make an instance of this
hpy and then this is HP and I say Heap
and I get
a snapshot and you see how much memory
is used here you can see the memory and
it's broken down for data types
so strings then dictionary of module and
so on and has a breakdown of those
different data types and shows you how
many percent are stored are used by this
different data types
yeah
and then you can just I may just a big
list I now I'm an interactive session
and I make a big list and if I do this I
get a new picture here
and look at the hip again and then you
see now it's very obvious it's full of
ins you see I made a list of million ins
and of course now you have 61 used by
instant 20 20 used by the list itself
yeah so the list itself just has
references and uh to the end and then
the Indus own object and the object
itself has some overhead is bigger than
a reference obviously
and then you see that 81 of your memory
is used actually by this list because it
didn't it didn't have it before and I'll
just increment that you have here and
you can see that the list is using this
memory
so you can do this um
when you when I delete my list now I
delete my list then I'm pretty much the
same state you will see if you do this
repeatedly we'd always get some
different numbers seems like it's always
changing and those numbers are not very
exact so they cannot be used for small
quantities but they can be very useful
for big so if you have memory problems
typically you have problems with a lot
of memory usage and then it works if you
have just if you want to see small
differences you won't see a lot so let's
look at them some example what you can
do you can use set ref and actually set
ref
sets it back to some kind of zero level
so that's what I'm
there are still a few here there are
still a few bytes used as you can see
here that's kind of something you cannot
get rid of that has over some error
connected with it but this is pretty
much your Baseline it's zero now you can
say set ref now you can do something and
can measure again and can see how how it
changed that's what I'm doing now so I
can create my Peak list again and then I
do another uh
hip here and then you see now you see
pretty much this is about 99 sitting in
my list
so the one percent is somehow some kind
of error which does a measurement
problems but you can see when you do the
set raft before
do something what you want to do and do
this Heap again then you see the
difference what happens with your memory
when it gets an breakdown so you don't
have actually the memory for every
single object but you can see the
difference before and after
so that's not perfect but it can be
pretty useful but of course you can
actually measure something you can see
the difference
here
yeah you could just kind of put it in
your program from time to time and see
if this if those things are getting
bigger and big on what what causes your
changes in memory
so uh then you can get a lot of
information out so if you you have this
if you make the instance of this Heap
here you can say set and then you have
the size here and then you do it again
then the size goes down
then I create my big list and you can
have size so you don't get this big
print out there but you get one number
for the size and this is number you can
calculate and you can see what what
happens and how things how things work
actually
and
I keep doing this here I said ref this
is pretty pretty much my zero yeah I set
it back to zero and then I create my big
list and you'll see that this is a
difference yeah this is a very small
number there's bytes then this is pretty
much my my Roc how accurate is it
approximately
and then I
set my reference again and you see when
I'll do it again I'm pretty much back to
zero more or less
yeah and then you have multiple options
what you can do with this this is object
this is memory object so to speak and
you can access single lines you can
you can ever order everything but all
kind of criteria one that would be
divide by type and other criteria is you
can have some information what's going
on with your memory and that's very
often the most important thing this is
optimization if the if you know the
problem that's actually the problem is
the solution might be pretty simple
actually very often it's difficult to
find out what the problem is well where
the memory goes and if you find this one
then very often at least my experience
you say oh yeah that's pretty obvious
but I didn't see it because yeah that's
how it goes
finding the problem is pretty much the
biggest
thing the biggest achievement so you
have more do you see more output more
more lines and you also can call it by a
referral so you have multiple options
what you can do with this data and you
see a lot of a lot of output here
so now I have I have an example here so
that's the source code you also have
let's go through this here
what you actually can do with this with
this memory thing so that's just the
plain Library you now have the example
how I could use it and I I use it I
write my own decorator and use a
decorator to do something see I have
here a global memory dictionary
and import my HPI
hpy from from guppy and func tools Funk
tools I need to write a nice decorator
so if you don't know about The Decorator
is then this might look a bit weird to
you so this is this is a new decorator
on this decorator is called measure
memory and this takes takes a function
that's supposed to be measured and then
it's doing the magic here because now it
creates a replacement function that's
going to replace my function and then it
has as you might have seen this one star
double star syntax that takes all kinds
of arguments and now I do the same thing
I did before but I don't do it
repeatedly in my code over the place but
only once that's important if you find
yourself copying pasting things many
times then there should be a better
solution and The Decorator can be a good
solution for this so actually I create
an instance of this hpy set the
reference back to zero
that's my initial memory here my initial
memory size then I call my function
and return the result
and at the end I just saw my memory I
put everything in the try except just
just in case this functions throws an
exception I still have the memory
yeah because finally it will be called
and it is just a normal dictionary when
every function has a name so I use a
function name and stored in function
name
you have to be careful if you do this
this works only if if all the functions
have you you need names if you apply
this decorate on many places then you
might also want to put the module name
in there so it's a different with every
function should have this module name
but if you just put it in one file then
it works it's just the principle and
then here of course I make another
snapshot of my memory and take off the
original one
that's pretty much what I did before on
single steps yeah but now I put it in
this decorator thing and then I have to
return this function so this underscore
thing is a dynamically created function
that's going to replace the other
function
and you should always use functory wraps
to make it look nice otherwise you would
lose your name and your dog string all
kind of things that's right that's how
how a decorator looks like the
decorators can be a bit involved if
you're not used to this thing but just
take it as a recipe so you which kind
takes a snapshot of the memory before
the function call and after the function
call and stores the difference between
both in this dictionary memory
and once we have this running then you
can test it
and that's how you use it you just say
measure memory here and then the measure
the memory difference of this core
before and after the function code will
be measured for you and will start will
be stored in this dictionary
so that's a very easy yeah and this is
also just a decorator and we've seen
before you could replace this decorate
of The Decorator do nothing so if you
have to decorate of 150 times in your
code you don't have to comment it out
you just replace the decorator do
nothing and your code would run without
any problems the only override would be
in the very beginning 150 times moving
functions through this decorated doing
nothing but in our case now we measure
the memory
and then just print it out it's just an
example if you run the command line you
would see the result just because they
have don't have much time I can do it
interactively this just takes quite a
bit time if you type everything
so now we have this example and if you
look at it you get
uh
um
no output yeah
maybe we need maybe I need to run it
and
I would have output
then I probably need
to go and run this file
so this is a file
memory size so I can run it from the
command line because I have it installed
there
so no I don't know uh I pass a notebook
here just run it from the command line
yeah so I have the one the first one is
called measure
um
measure size I think
the first one
and this is a
check what's the name of the file is
yeah measure size so if I if I run this
with normal python here and say uh
measures measure size and memory size is
called memory size
HP and then you see uh that's a that
that's a memory
I use here so this is stored he has a
dictionary with a function name that is
The Decorator puts this function name in
here as I said if you want to make it a
bit more usable you should also put the
module name that would be unique
otherwise you have two functions the
same name the last one would override it
and then you see that's a used memory
of my of my function of this function
I'm using here
somehow
doesn't react to you so this this is my
function down here but I'm using and
this is just actually returning a number
this this list range number returns
number so there's actually a a change in
memory you can also measure the growth
of a memory how memory is growing so we
have this memory course hpy here py and
then it's a similar thing I also write
this one this takes a function argument
so this time I decided not using a
decorator but use a different approach
just use a normal function that takes a
function as a first input so you can
also do this it has everything has
advantages disadvantages The Decorator
you have to apply in your code and write
it there and here I can just import the
module and run it to my test module in
test functions that's what I'm doing I
do the same thing I Make an instance I
set everything to zero I get the size I
call my function and I measure again
that's pretty much the same thing I did
before but with a different technology I
just don't use decorate I just use a
function which is also for other use
cases can be useful
and then I do the same thing I have a
test here and see the first test is
again returning uh returning my my list
of the many numbers here and here uh
actually I
go through those numbers and append
something
uh
to
this list
but I don't
I don't return it there
uh actually I I don't return by
appendages data here to this list I
append this X and let it grow step by
step and every time
this list grows and then if you run this
one then
you have a different I have to go back
to my my shell and see how these how
things are running so I have this python
memory grows and then you see how it's
how it's growing
memory grow
HP
and then you see if you make this make
big in this case because uh
I don't store this big list yeah I
created but that's right away the
garbage collector collects it
essentially essentially this is
essentially my zero here this number and
the other one if you say if a pen this
to this globalist you have this change
so this is again go back to the uh
to this um
there's a source code here this is the
first one you see this Returns the range
but I don't I don't save the return I
throw the return away there's nobody uh
doing it and here I have it have this
data and this data stays around and I've
put something in data and then I measure
I use uh
this check memory and put it through
yeah
yeah but I don't save the result the the
result of this one is saved in this in
this Global here well actually it's in
it's in the test function but it's saved
in data and here I don't do anything
with the result of the memory is not
used so you can see the effect so it's
very often to do some kind of uh check
that that the thing the tool works just
like like you think
and that's always a good experience and
if things work so there's another tool
which works similarly so each SSH this
the CP the existed only for thousand two
point six for quite a while and you had
to compile for Python 2.7 which is
usually another good thing if because it
was not easy to get it compiled there's
another tool called pimpler on pimploy
actually is a grew out of three other
objects uh projects and they put it
together and now this is very similar
and you can also use it and you can use
a similar technology to do it and
compare those results also
but if you do this uh if you use this
mem tracker here which I
uh import yeah I Make an instance of the
summary tracker and then if you look at
the diff you see the diffs from before
this is supposed to be zero because
nothing happened
and if you do it again and again sooner
or later you will get to zero there's
always some kind of a little bit
measuring error of objects you have you
want to get
get to zero and then I have another
the same approach the same decorate
approach so the code is pretty much the
same we had before but it just used a
summary tracker and do something here
and you see I do something five times
and try to set it to zero so I call this
that rough five times to get close to
zero to stiff then I call my function
return my function save thing so this is
exactly the same and you can do the same
thing with pimpla do you have a second
tool and
it's a good thing we have two tools if
it has the same result it might be right
if they're different results one of the
must should be wrong opposal wrong who
knows yeah that's something you can do
with simple so it's pretty much the same
code as this this described to you in
text and then we have the same thing
here with memory grows I use this same
approach and again I run five times set
it this diff to set it to zero and then
do another div and return this one and
you can see the
uh
the memory that's used in between this
is exactly the same code we just looked
at before that's something you can do
and that really can be it can be useful
for things and I want to show you some
interesting example
yeah
uh of course now we want that we
actually want to measure how the memory
is allocated for list or something and
it might be very interesting so and I
use different functions I use this
pimpler offers two functions size of a
flat size they have different meanings
and you will see how how this works and
then you can
hear I inject so to speak the the method
I would like to use in this case flat
size is a is a
the default and but I also can use size
off and I just make an empty list
and just measure the size of of my list
right and I'll put it in the list and
then I go through many times and I
append this list so my list I append
something my list I want to measure and
this mem is my result of the measurement
and you see I also say append when I
append the size of the list so these two
pens are totally different things this
is my object I want to measure and this
is my result and I just continuously
append the size so you should see the
how the size is growing with every
append every pen should be some increase
or not if it's the same size for some
reason and that's what I'm doing here on
virtual memory
yeah and now I just have a small test
function where you have the size
in here and now I go through now I can
write a a loop over this different
function or flat size a size and just
get size of this assist from the
standard Library so
python functions or objects so you can
put them a list write a list a loop of a
functions and you don't have to write it
three times you just do it once and then
I just call this this function I just
wrote I put in the thousand and then
here I Supply this function in there
which is important and then
I try to do the method make a nice plot
out of it so if I if my blood works I do
a plot otherwise I just show a textual
output so everything in here just try
except it's just output this makes you
just normal very simple plot a matte
plot lip and this one gives you the
whole thing as a table so if Matlock
installer shouldn't work if you have
anaconda or something then method will
be there for sure but if it don't it's
just a plain python store then you get a
table those kind of things there's a bit
tooling here and you could extend this
tooling and if you do something like
this
you get this Pro this if you call Flat
size then you get only the size uh the
size of the list itself then you see
that's very interesting how the size of
the list goes because the list doesn't
grow continuously python is always
allocating more memory than you need and
then filling the elements that's very
important for for efficiency and if you
have like if you can measure if you have
100 million appends to a list you have
about 100 allocations
you know handle those steps and I have
thousand you see they're getting bigger
and bigger and bigger the very small
steps and to pick up the list gets you
get about more or less it's not exactly
50 more memory then you can see how the
list itself grows that's very
interesting
but you can also see if you use the the
size off then you get the whole list
including all the elements in the list
all the numbers I put in this case I put
only
integer so you could have more diffic
more complicated things and now you see
uh there's a different thing because now
also measure the all the numbers every
time I append the number python creates
a new integer
and this integers measure also and you
see the numbers much bigger of course
yeah but it's pretty much steady or do
you see this this jump is pretty small
compared to it this goes to 35 000 and
here it only goes to ten thousand the
scale so it's about three and a half
times as much more or less
memory use because the user numbers also
so this gives you a lot of
kind of feeling what happens with your
pro with your program and this might
help you later on to to find
maybe it's a box somewhere or some kind
of a limitation thing you did you can
change
the problem if you don't know what is
you have to guess and try and it can be
a very difficult game if you have
something like this and you see the
picture a lot of things might get much
clearer immediately
so if you use the the built-in function
assist get size of it's the same as flat
size so the python itself has has
this get size of any object and if you
do this for this list I get I get
something like this and this is
essentially the same thing as flat size
so that helps you to measure
memory and
now we also have the growth of the list
if you grow a list at this it's the same
things here and just have the
have it going here and you see you have
the the size of an integer here and then
you have this the old size of a list
which I take off and then I just go
through here and
gets the size of my list it's a new size
and then you I subtract from the new
size the old size
and if this is greater than in I I add
this add a step and then I set the old
size in root size and return let's see
how many steps it takes and you see how
many allocation this is to find out how
many allocation steps you have just
measuring those steps ahead in this in
this this graphic domain account and by
hand that's just a simple thing you
measure whenever this is is growing then
you get a
um
a number and you see that's that's the
allocation so you see if you have tender
pens we have about three allocations and
if you have that's a million FF 10
million you have about
yeah that's 10 million you have about
100 allocations
but it gives you some overhead some
insight what python is doing and get
size of and flat size office give you
the same result and this is
then you know okay a pen is a very you
know this earlier you can look it up but
you have a have it as numbers but the
pen is actually doing to your list on
how things are growing so this gives you
some maybe some flavor that you can do
with those tools you can get inside you
have to be creative because your problem
might be different and you have the
building blocks to build your own small
tools and this is decorator approach I
showed you can actually put them in your
code and turn them off just by this one
switch using a decorator that's doing
nothing I think that's a pretty good
technique so you because you want to
automate as much as possible when the
computer that do the work and not
yourself going in there and at 1050
placing copying something or commenting
something out that's not nothing you
want to do usually in a business
decorator approach you can actually keep
this inside in production code and just
turn it off if you want to it doesn't
have any effect only at compile time
when you produce a byte code and import
things which is very quick usually it
doesn't really matter most of the time
there'll be very few cases where this
could be a problem
okay uh there's also the equivalent to
this line profiler there's a memory
profiler which is going line by line so
you can also get uh your your memory
measured line by line this can be
interesting so you can
run a bit out of time you can do this
line by line and then you can
have this have this function here with a
lot of things what I'm doing and then
you can use this memory profile and
running line by line when you see a line
by line breakthrough here how much
memory everything takes what you're
doing you see this is a list
comprehension if I use a list
comprehension and then make a sum I use
quite a bit in memory if you use a
generator expression maker sum
you it's it's even too small to show
that's very interesting list
comprehension generator expression
difference you see what what happens
there
and you can get some feeling uh how much
memory it takes you see this one uses
without so much memory and if you delete
it it refreeze it so it gives you some
insight what's happening with the memory
but it can be interesting as academic
exercise to know but if you have a
problem then you can pretty much follow
where the memory goes so that would be
so if you narrowed it down this is a
business bigger tool then you take the
line memorable file on your go line by
line and you can do the same thing
and soon if you do it for this very big
number here then you get a pretty big
difference in terms of memory usage for
those kind of things I don't know why
it's 90 here sometimes you have to be
aware that sometimes those two will make
me take mistakes the Conover is a
problem memory measurements stuff like
this is not that easy
and sometimes there's two the tools
might make a mistake and if you use it
in a different world or something which
would give the same result it gives
different results or something
that's something that can happen and you
can print this out and you see uh
these things
okay see I'm how much more time do we
have
okay only three minutes so I'm probably
did a
didn't get everything through I think
the measurement is my my important thing
that's actually uh to find out that the
problems are then the solutions there
are a lot of solutions and I want to go
through a few of them or actually the
handout has has them the some solutions
also small algorithmic changes which can
be very amazing at places and the other
solutions would be actually using big
tools and if you if you hear the
conference you will see a lot of those
big tools which are numpy foreign
Copperhead and all kind of things so
there's a lot of different things you
can do depending on the problem you have
so there's no real General
recommendation what to use and this
would be the second part which I totally
skipped now because we are pretty much
out of time
but I think the measurement is is very
important that you get the feeling that
the problem could be and then you can
start using some of those tools and
putting it in as I have another example
with all those tools but the first in
the I think there's the most important
thing is you have to find out what the
problem is and narrow down the problem
if you have 100 000 lines of code the
domain can look of every line of code
you want to narrow down with a few
important lines that might cause a
problem and this is uh this is the thing
the other half of the next section if
you if you come to read through would be
about small kind of recipes doing things
uh python what what is what is pythonic
in pure Python and then I have example
calculating pi and using different types
of tools and looking at the differences
you get out of it
and as I said there's even more tools
and I can even touch here but you will
see a lot of those in action here at the
conference of other tutorials other
talks about the things so the extreme
coordination is one of the things we
have patterns and lists and generate
Expressions we looked already on the
memory usage which is also
time usage if you can use General
expression you save a lot of time
and local local and Global variables
we did this with this mass square root
for instance there's a lot there's a lot
of small things you can do Small Tricks
here and there instead of using a global
using a local variable here so something
instead of going doing since Global here
saying the local is the global
actually this would give you
quite a bit of difference if you do this
and look at this you need but you are 25
faster 25 is quite a bit just for the
small assignment and those kind of
things you can try the problem is you
should never just you should measure if
it's very effective they might not be
effective because other things are much
more important than the small things and
it's difficult to to guess sometimes
they're guessing something and it's I
was really off yeah that happens but if
you measure you
you're probably better off doing this
when you're doing the profiling and see
things yeah using the built-in names and
local names it's even worse if you set
true to True here then you save a lot of
time because now you don't have to go to
the all the way up to true and look for
the true just as a local tree if you
need it a lot in this thing then you
have about 40 savings
then of course data structures which is
an important topic so that just can
maybe have a few minutes run through
if you use built-in data structures you
most most of the time much better than
coming up is anything else of your own
so you get a lot of comfort and a lot of
Speed Most of the time and have a few
examples here using lists or sets for
different types of things so that can be
very fast for different types of things
you can do just some examples here just
you have to skip over and you compare
something when you see the difference
between these two this would be
something
you probably I don't have so much time
here
and
this is just an example this or there
are some special data structures Empires
like a deck is a double-ended queue in
Python that can be useful for a few
things and I have an example for this
one so it's not always better that can
be also use cases that are slower
actually and I measure this year as an
example doing some few things which is
of course not you can understand
immediately what it means defaultict is
in Python
in collections that can do a few things
so so small things that might be useful
they might not bring anything and then
this is maybe the the let's conclude
this is this is a overview of this
What's called the Big O notation so the
the complexity of algorithm how long it
actually takes and you want to stay with
those ones are very nice because o1
means they're independent of the size so
if you say A Lang list it doesn't matter
how long the list is it takes the same
if it lists as one element or one
billion elements it doesn't matter it
takes about the same amount of time to
do this and a few few other things like
typically X and dictionary in the normal
case it's independently so that's why if
you search for something use
dictionaries or sets not this if you can
if you do it often the course are much
faster this one is depending linear so
if if this list is twice as big that
takes twice as long if you do something
loops
and log n so it's getting a bit longer
so sorting typically in Python sorting
is pretty optimized but it's typically
how long it takes and then nested Loops
for instance would be quadratic and this
would be
pretty bad already so if you have a
million elements A Million by a million
is 10 to the power of 12 and can take a
long time
doing everything higher
you shouldn't even consider so that's
something you you should you can know
about which which data type that's
pretty much what you did before with the
examples now just a little more
formalized in this table and put
together and this is some small things
but those small things can be effective
it should obviously Reach For Those
simplest things small things first and
look for them you might solve your
problem you don't have to go for the
bigger guns and do bigger things like
using uh gpus or whatever you you think
you might be it might be just changing
if you go from here to there that can be
a big difference or if you could from
there to there so if instead of looking
looking in the list all the time looking
at a dictionary it can be gigantic
difference of many many orders of
magnitude you will never get with any
compilers on your tools so that's just
algorithm data structures are
interconnected because the data
structures come with algorithms in
Python how to how to work with them
Okay so uh this is the data structure
thing and then you have some examples
for this here where I have some
different kind of data things I'm using
and measuring things and code examples
always with numbers so
see and then that's the difference here
2 300 times faster or slower whatever
you want to look at
things so everything comes with numbers
here you can see that I like to have C
numbers at the end when you fast and
slow us maybe not enough and then have a
bunch of examples here for these kind of
so they have more more things about
caching I don't know how long we can run
over caching would be one thing if you
need to recalculate things again and
again and again the caching would be one
technology and they have some recipes
here how to do caching again using
decorators all the way through which is
pretty complex you can do caching and
can put things in caches it's a
decorator putting things in caches so
this that Technologies and recipes or
things you can
we can do and different kind of things
if you can empty your cash or not this
this of course we don't have time list
recently used cash actually there's now
in Python 3 has it in a
in a standard Library so you don't need
to implement yourself but can be
interesting to see how those caching
works
okay then the next thing would be if you
look to the handout just to give you a
short Outlook using different methods to
using numeric code to use Monte Carlo to
calculate pi which is very simple but
very computationally demanding algorithm
and now I use different things to to do
this fortunately this is embarrassing
parallel so you can parallelize the heck
out of it if you like to no problem and
then you can use pretty much all tools
you have better off the device is not
that nice and you cannot parallelize
things like this this would be the
the next thing yeah out of time is this
right
kind of yeah so story is a bit a bit too
much but I think that my main point was
the measuring thing and then giving you
some some things to do we see a lot more
tools doing things fast in the
conference uh so maybe the focusing on
the measuring and profiling kind of
thing is important that already know if
they have a case to go for the big tools
or not and then there's a lot of small
things that are very easy not much
effort you could do and as I would
recommend you go for the algorithm first
if you can improve your algorithm you
can get the Thousand or ten thousand
times faster maybe if you've already
have a problem with your algorithm and
no other tools would give you this
speed up in any
any case
okay so let's go to the
to the end here so the end has a
has a just overview of those different
types of tools so some of them are
introduced in the course some of them I
don't so there are some
some tools here you can use just by by
no way exhaustive and I've just learned
a few
to talk during the break that there are
more tools I should put in this table so
it's a bunch of tools that can do a lot
of things
but as I said they won't be totally
helpful if your algorithm is off they
they might be slower than a very nice
personal algorithm but that's a very
first thing you should do
okay
we should stop now because there's break
we want to stay in in time sorry for
this kind of condensed thing because
maybe there's so much you can do with
optimization we have so little time but
hopefully you get a good overview we
have the source code you have the
handouts if you don't have one pick one
up
and if you have a question you can have
questions now it also ask me in the
break thank you very much